it puts everybody into this behavior
modification regime that even if it
doesn't do what it's supposed to it has
all these side effects it makes
everybody a bit more vain and crazy and
stupid and uh contentious and paranoid
that does happen it's really good at
that and because of that
it becomes this giant invitation to the
worst actors in the world to try to go
in
and sabotage other people's societies
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kishan
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is
somebody we've been trying to get onto
the show literally since the day we
started he's an american computer
scientist visual artist computer
philosophy writer technologist futurist
and composer of contemporary classical
music as well he's considered one of the
founders of the field of virtual reality
jaren lanier welcome to trigonometry
hey how's it going
it's going great listen man before we
get into of what we hope is going to be
a brilliant and fascinating conversation
uh tell everybody a little bit about
your story who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
oh gosh you know i find that to be a
confusing question
i i
um well let's see um
i'm known for a few different things and
to different communities of people some
people only know me one way or the other
uh i i
approximately started virtual reality uh
i came up with the term and i had the
first startup and pioneered a lot of the
apps and devices and whatnot a long time
ago in the 80s when i was
a kid in my wasted years yes
i write books that are critical about
technology i'm very concerned that we
have a responsibility as computer
scientists to think about what we're
doing to the world
and when it's not working we have to be
honest about it and so i've written a
bunch of books um the best known one
might be the 10 arguments uh for
deleting your social media accounts now
right now um but another one is called
you're not a gadget and i'm very
skeptical of the idea of artificial
intelligence i'm very skeptical of the
business models for social media and
other things
i'm very concerned about them and then
uh yet another thing is uh as an actual
computer scientist i do all kinds of
things we don't have to get into that
because it'll put you to sleep but it's
actually extremely important and prevent
and then um
uh i do other stuff too but i think
that's enough to get going
sure well you've covered three things
there that francis and i are really keen
to talk to you about which is ai virtual
reality and of course social media i
think we best start with social media
because i i feel like
of all the different stories we've
covered on the show the different guests
we've talked to
the polarization
the tone of our public discourse the
behavior of children in terms of their
self-image and their body image the
i mean any issue that is affecting
modern society really
there is a role that social media has
played and by the way you know francis
and i are both
content creators i love using twitter
for example to talk to you know hundreds
of thousands of people on a daily basis
i think it's an incredible piece of
technology but we're also paying a heavy
heavy price for some of these benefits
talk to us about your broad take on on
social media you talk about the business
model and the problems with that what
are some of the the impacts that we are
seeing in the world in your opinion and
where they come from
well okay
the first thing i want to say is that
in the biggest picture something similar
to social media as we know it would be
great
like i i worked really hard to help get
the internet to happen
which is a story we can talk about if
you want what my role was but i still
believe in the idea of a more connected
world i still believe in the idea
of people being able to have
reach in new ways i all of that's great
the problem that came up is the business
model which had a perverse effect of
promoting the worst sides of human
nature
okay so it's a business model problem
more than a technology problem and i
really want people to remember that
because a lot of times somebody will
come up to me and say well there's this
or that about whatever social media
platforms they like that i love and how
can you say that i should quit it and
that it's all horrible and i said you
know i never told you to quit i gave you
arguments i want you to think i want you
to be responsible for your choices but
the good stuff is authentic
like it would be absurd to argue that
the authentic that the good stuff is
inauthentic because that's ridiculous i
mean it's playing in front of our faces
that they're good things
um
my personal favorite one remains an
oldie but goody which is people with
unusual diseases can find each other and
share notes and that used to be
impossible that to me is a great
concrete example of something that the
technology has brought into the world
that otherwise would not be in the world
that has kept people alive i love that
all right so i mean it should be obvious
however
what happened was
for a lot of really stupid reasons the
early internet companies ended up with
this bizarre business model and the
business model
is
uh you pretend to be socialist in the
users experience but the way you're
capitalist as fake capitalists too you
end up with the worst of both worlds
instead of the best of both worlds
so um you're fake socialist in the sense
that you say oh sharing is great to
share your information and we'll give
you free stuff
but the problem is there has to be a
customer somewhere because it's still a
world driven by business and so the
customers who come in
think that what they're buying is mind
control they think that what they're
buying is so much access to user data
and so much access to giant algorithms
that can predict user behavior that they
can just pour money into
alphabet or meta google or facebook and
out will come massive behavior
modification that will throw elections
or get people to buy products or
whatever it is
or or commit to a religion all kinds of
crazy stuff
or just
cynically
um bring about a a quicker end to
civilization or something whatever the
person's into
the thing is
a lot of that stuff doesn't even work i
i've been around the meetings where the
big companies sell the biggest clients
to pour money into this and
honestly i don't think you get a lot of
mind control i do think you get two
things though
i think you get
uh
just a few big companies
holding the ability to blackmail
everybody by controlling access of
everybody to everybody so in other words
it's just the opposite what the internet
was supposed to be is connecting
everyone and instead we have universal
blackmail of
forcing people to behave in certain ways
to get connected which is the opposite
of what was supposed to happen
so that's stupid but then the
the other thing is that
even if the mind control to get somebody
to buy a particular soap is pretty
sketchy and i think a lot of times the
data to support it is sketchy
what it does do is it puts everybody
into this behavior modification regime
that even if it doesn't do what it's
supposed to it has all these side
effects it makes everybody a bit more
vain and crazy and stupid and uh
contentious and paranoid
that does happen it's really good at
that and because of that
it becomes this giant invitation to the
worst actors in the world to try to go
in
and sabotage other people's societies so
you have uh the lovely mr putin uh
having these
basements in saint petersburg
uh create fake black activists to try to
make uh the black political movements in
the u.s more radical in order to
destabilize american society and make it
kind of nutty
that's documented i'm just using that
example because it's well documented
there's many many others that are coming
as well
and so
um
you overall have this thing that darkens
human prospects it makes everybody like
i say just a little like a lesser
version of themselves a little more vain
a little more mature a little more
paranoid a little more
ornery and
irritable and all of that is in service
of a business model that doesn't really
deliver a lot of real value it just
creates artificial impediments to what
would otherwise happen in my opinion so
i think it's a massive massive screw-up
and it happened
you know i was around google when it was
very very small before facebook existed
i sold them a company i used to know
sergey and larry
they were so cute so full of energy so
optimistic
and uh the thing is
that the surrounding social circumstance
was incredibly adamant about two
different
needs that were totally in contradiction
with one another on the one hand
there was this leftist feeling because
it's the bay area in california and
everybody's supposed to share the
internet is finally a chance to get rid
of the evils of capitalism
but on the other hand we love our
business hacker heroes we love our
entrepreneurs we we love our steve jobs
you know and so you're supposed to be
this great business person but you're
supposed to hate business you know like
how do you get those things to work
and the way to do it is by being fake
where you create fake socialism as an
experience and fake capitalism on the
back end you don't get like whatever you
believe about either of them
you know these this is the worst of both
of them it's it's like the worst
possible solution but in a way it's the
only one
the social pressures of the time would
allow to happen jaren can you dig in for
us into that particular thing a little
bit more
what is the i understand that
me as a twitter user i'm not the
customer it's the advertiser that's the
customer but beyond that how how is the
business model making us
different and when you talk about fake
socialism and fake capitalism dig in
into that a little bit more for us
yeah sure so um
there's uh we have to go a little bit
into the science behind behavior
modifications so this backwards it goes
to the 19th century with yvonne pavlov
yet another russian i see you have a
mock russian poster behind it well i'm
from russia originally so that's my
heritage okay yeah and i'm from
venezuela so i've seen socialism done
properly
okay uh excellent excellent
uh
so um we're all extremely well informed
here
yeah
so
pavlov talk to us about pavlova and his
beautiful dogs one of the early
behaviorists and so these are people who
said we're going to do a methodical
mathematical scientific approach to
understanding how training works
so of course people have been training
animals and for that matter other people
since ancient times
there's nothing new about that but this
was saying okay we're in the scientific
age we're going to do it methodically
and so um
uh
pavlov started to experiment with like
you're going to put a creature in a cage
and control exactly what stimuli are
available and exactly what outcomes are
available so you can really get focused
information about what works and what
doesn't work to understand
behaviorism in the 20th century probably
the most famous uh heir to pavlov was bf
skinner
he's doing the same thing in skinner's
case mostly with pigeons and rats
uh you put them in a cage
there are a few very interesting things
that came out of this methodical
approach to training
one thing
is that it can
get out of control so if you put if you
put an animal in a cage and you say if
you hit this button you'll get a treat
if you hit this other button you'll get
an electric shock let's say
they'll just sit there hitting the treat
button
what happens is it changes the nature of
an organism
or a creature from one that has
multi-level behaviors that can respond
to different circumstances and can learn
to one that's very simple just stuck on
a little loop
okay that's a very important thing to
observe all right that's one thing
another thing that's extremely
interesting is that if you want
to
deeply embed a behavioral pattern in in
the creature instead of just having
perfect feedback
where when you hit the button you
immediately get the candy every time
you add a bit of randomness or it might
take a while longer
and this bit of randomness what it does
is it absorbs the brain's ability to
adapt and focus it entirely on this
because the brain is like what's going
on what's going on
and so it actually strengthens
the conditioning okay so this is
sometimes called operant conditioning
there are many variations and i could
i could flip into technical talk to to
create many shades of distinction but
i think i'm giving you a fair summary of
how this stuff works
um the people who studied this had
different opinions
about
uh how it should be applied to human
beings
okay now at the dawn of computers
one of the founding computer scientists
was um
wrote a book called the human use of
human beings
and this was a book pointing out
that
with the advent of computers you could
automate this whole thing instead of
having white coated lab researchers
doing it and there's a danger that
people could make machines that would
just make each other trained in a way
that they become crazy and very narrow
and it could really be extremely
dangerous for
civilization uh that was a book in the
50s
sadly forgotten human use of human
beings
but then we hit the 60s and something
really interesting happens
it's famously known that a little a
little into the late 60s the the
beginning of the technology the internet
happened uh
funded in the united states by military
research i was trying to come up with a
communications networks that could
survive a nuclear attack by being very
adaptable right
but before that
there was a cruder technology for
networking that was the first time
computers were actually networked at
distances for people to use
and this was an experimental uh
network that ran only between
universities in the american midwest
and guess who got the job of designing
the user experience in it
none other than rbf skinner
so the very first network experiment
with real people was by a behaviorist
and his attitude i think was quite wrong
really wrong-headed what he thought
is that if you could get everybody
onto computers that are networked and
you could put everybody under the
influence of these algorithms you could
engineer
a society
that would become stable and productive
and happy and perfect
that's the right reaction it's funny
right it strikes this as a laugh line it
seems ridiculous but
um there are a couple of amazing things
about it which is that bf skinner was on
the western capitalist side of the cold
war and yet what he was saying was not
unlike what was happening on the other
side this is exactly what people in
places like east germany and north korea
and many other places have tried to do
using other means to sort of
put people under enough behavioral
control and sensory control that you can
engineer this perfect coherent society
to your liking and jumping ahead a
little bit jared it's exactly like what
china is doing now to its own citizens
as we know right
right and unfortunately i think china
learned some tricks from our tech
companies in this case something that i
mean i find shameful yeah but anyway
sorry for interrupting you carry on
that's right so look anyway um so
skinner did this experiment didn't work
particularly well it was a tiny crude
experiment mostly forgotten actually
um
so then um
uh the internet happens initially
between military sites and universities
but this is the radical 60s so there's
this kind of hippie
thing which hey listen i'm part of it
i'm a hippie
proud of it but at any rate
there was this hippie sensibility that
was anti-capitalism not exactly pro
soviet or pro
the other side but definitely in this
other space and in in um
somewhat naively utopian on many levels
i say that as somebody who's tried to
live in the 60s commune and whatnot
it's hard people are hard you can't just
pretend people are easy when people are
hard i mean this is a fundamental issue
that the left never gets
right
but anyway um
the uh
uh so then when companies like google
show up the rhetoric around computer
culture which is and computer culture is
incredibly powerful i mean it's not
this has never been an entirely top-down
thing this is a community cultural
effort and computer culture is is
anti-capitalist on the surface but as i
say also pro-capitalist as long as
you're happy here hacker hero
entrepreneur you know
so it doesn't make sense and it doesn't
um we were absolutely unwilling to take
three seconds to step back and notice
our own contradictions
right
um it seems ridiculous but you know very
human i think
so google was born with this ridiculous
hippie illusion in front even though
it's actually a company
and i have to say
um
uh
i i'm putting it this way because i'm
pretty sure that the original people who
made google
would have been just as happy to do it
differently but the community pressure
was so intense that they weren't really
given a practical choice
it was like this very intense dogma
um
like as an example
um
i'll say some things here that might
upset some some people who are listening
but like in the early days 20 years ago
or whatever um a bit more than that
actually
like
the seeming good guys who had nothing
but very high self-regard like the
pirate parties in europe
were feeding google business while
pretending to be anarchists and
anti-capitalists
and that was plainly true obviously true
to everybody they were even funded by
google in many cases and yet somehow
everybody just ignored this and i think
it's an incredible testament
to how people
will be happily ready to lie to
themselves if it's comfortable
and i think that's universal that's not
just a problem with this particular
community it's a universal human quality
and he sneaks up on us all the time
hey constantine do you want better
mental health i'm from russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the bears feelings it's
russian bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my adhd
and become better in all areas of my
life
why is he telling them how weak he is
drink vodka feel better better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
forward slash trigger especially if
they're not real men that's b e t t e r
h e l p
dot com slash trigger
we're talking about the worst of
capitalism but these companies in many
ways are the worst of capitalism they're
monopolies they're incredibly powerful
they now have the ability to influence
elections like what we like we saw with
hunter biden and twitter suppressing the
story i mean it's terrifying isn't it
well
a couple things to say there
one thing is i get calls from all kinds
of people who are upset about
what uh what happened to elections uh
i
have more first-hand knowledge than most
people about what happened in the
platforms and
there was more suppression of the left
than the right
both things happened but just to be
clear about that
there was more stuff that happened that
was antibiotic than pro biden
like what tell us because i'm i've never
heard this argument i'm very open to it
like what give can you give us some
examples uh
the
documented for real and high volume
foreign interventions that favor a
candidate favor trump
mostly driven by russia
to say that that's all that happened
would be ridiculous because all kinds of
things were happening but the weight of
it went in that direction does that mean
anything no actually it doesn't i know
that
um
it's frequently you kind of want to
believe like if you're more sympathetic
to one side than the other side you kind
of want to believe the other side's got
more advantage or whatever
honestly this whole thing is a big
giant bundle of [ __ ] anyway like i
think to worry about whether the other
side got more [ __ ] than your side
is
really irrelevant
the point is there should be no [ __ ]
certainly no argument there at all but
john can i just can i just challenge you
briefly on this point one more challenge
you know look i know i've been through
this argument a lot i i really want to
emphasize
i do believe i have a clear picture of
it on the other hand i just really don't
think it matters or it's that important
if it strikes you as being important i
really want you i want you to reconsider
whether it is
well that's why i want to ask you the
question because i am totally open for
you to persuade me it's unimportant the
difference that i saw and look neither
francis or i are trump fans neither of
us is on the right
none of that right we're just
as a principle to me
watching a set of coordinated efforts by
different tech platforms to prevent a
story about the son of a of a
presidential candidate being published
on the eve of the election
that was unprecedented and very very
different to
uh
the tech platform messing around with
russian bot farms or whatever do you see
what i'm saying yeah i look i'm i
and you know what um
i
if you're gonna so if if the question
before us was
were there parties who work together
to try to support biden in ways that
make us uncomfortable about the future
of a decent honest society and democracy
the answer is yes there were
and i and so i can i would validate what
you're saying um i think i think that
happened in a few different levels i
think a part of it
was um
the fact that most people of influence
in the tech world are educated most
educated people
are more sympathetic to
the democrats in the us and to liberal
positions in general
and they naturally tend to support each
other when they start to move in that
direction and even without an explicit
conspiracy there can be an effective one
all right
i i i don't want to deny that there's
truth about that um i also
want to point out that some of what they
were resisting like if the question is
uh well they're different questions you
could say was there less reporting than
there might have otherwise been about
hunter biden
probably on the other hand a lot of the
promotion of the hunter biden story was
also equally questionable for the same
reasons
and with even more central or
essential coordination and more
questionable issues and more money
behind it to the best of my ability to
read it which is neither here nor there
in my view in the balance if you compare
all the different kinds of bias that
were injected into the social media
systems there was more pro-trump stuff
going on than pro-biden stuff
once again
neither here nor there and it it it
makes no sense for any of us to
adjudicate that if i'm wrong it really
wouldn't have any effect on any of the
positions i'm taking of consequence here
truly
that that being the case what do we do
with these hugely powerful companies
they uh you know they can pretty much do
what they want yeah they can control
what they want they they disseminate
information as they want they're too
powerful surely
yeah so this is very problematic so
going back to the book i mentioned the
human use of human beings and i didn't
mention the author norbert weiner i
should mention and i have to say this
book is really hard to read because this
guy's an ultra nerd and there's
mathematical equations in the middle of
it and
um
it's a great shame if he'd written it in
an accessible style i think it would
have changed the world but he just
wasn't that person you know at the time
this is going way way back this is to
the manhattan project generation of
scientists you know so anyway um
the problem is that if you have computer
networks running the world whoever
runs the networks runs the world it's
like a much more powerful thing than
money it's much more powerful than votes
it's what it's like the most powerful
thing because you're directly
in control of the channels of action
that exist in the civilization and
this was a danger that was well
articulated in advance by a variety of
people
i tried to say what i could about it at
the time as did a few others
honestly most of us in computer science
were just so enthralled by the prospect
of power that we allowed
are our kind of um
[Music]
i don't know our egos to get the best of
us oh we must this must be for the good
we're the best people we'll save the
world if we get powerful i mean it's and
of course that's fallacious
no nobody's perfect you know and no
concentration of power is trouble free
you know and so
um that
that's uh what happened and so now we do
have this kind of curious situation now
that said
there's a weird kind of neutered quality
to the new kind of power that
makes it a little less horrible than it
might be and if you want to look at the
comparison compare what companies like
meta and alphabet can do to what the
chinese are doing
right or the russians or the iranians or
just all kinds of other people like
there's a weird thing about silicon
valley culture if we can call that our
tech or tech culture and that it's so
nerdy it's so
we're not supposed to use the term on
the spectrum anymore but i don't really
know what language to use for this
there's this kind of dryness to it that
in a way it's not exactly traditional
power seeking and it doesn't have
traditional power goals it's more just
this kind
of nerd supremacy without a particular
direction or sensibility it's it's truly
different i think than previous
concentrations of power
i mean like you go to silicon valley and
every other center of power in history
has made itself beautiful and impressive
and silicon valley has not it's just
kind of another shitty suburb you know
and that's strange but it reflects this
kind of incredible nerdiness
uh
and so um if you talk to
zuckerberg it's just this kind of
very formulaic
um first order approximation of what an
idea would be like the world should be
more connected so we'll make it more
connected and that's to the good but
there's nothing more there's no
there's nothing there i mean of course
the individuals like getting rich but
they don't necessarily have anything to
do with that you know
um same thing at google it's it's kind
of an odd thing it's like we will
organize the world's information
which i think by the way is a misnomer
let's but that we don't need to go to
the philosophy of that but the thing is
it it's a weirdly neutered thing and so
the main problem with it is different
from the problem of
um
oh i don't know a putin-like figure who
wants to conquer a neighbor or a
she-like figure in china who wants to
create this sort of chinese-centric
model of the world that that gives no
room for for even the identity of
tibetans or uyghurs or taiwanese or
anything
it's not like either of those things
it's more
it's a weird thing it's like
the nerd kid in high school who doesn't
even really have
an agenda but just
is sick of being the one dumped on you
know it's a strange
inert kind of power to a degree
but because it has the side effect of
destroying the personnel harming the
personalities of everybody else
it still is how the effects are still
too negative and of course the other
thing to say is whenever you create a
center of power it'll eventually be
seized by the worst people
right you start off with bolsheviks then
you get stalinists that's how it works
and when you get rid of the stalinists
you don't suddenly get democrats you get
uh you yeah
you get some kind you get prudence you
know like like uh uh centers of power
are seductively horrible for history
so uh
there's a lot of reasons not to do it
but it's also important to understand
that when we talk about power of tech
companies it's a different kind of power
than we're used to historically
and john it seems to me that
like all revolutions it started off with
utopians people wanting to build a
better future people having an idealized
view of the world and how they were
going to change things for the better
and they were going to make everyone
more connected and society was going to
get
richer and
just better as a result without
realizing a the long the consequences of
their actions but b as well
you've got to monetize this thing and if
you're going to monetize it you want
people to stay on the platforms and how
you're going to do that
it's you're going to do it through
algoma algorithms and playing with
people's emotions
yeah just over
over the last weekend i uh keynoted or i
co-keynoted with neil stevenson who
wrote snow crash and many other science
fiction novels we uh the uh the big
crypto conference which is called
consensus uh put on by coindesk in
austin
which is kind of like
uh we call it a dumpster fire in our
current lingo but at any rate whatever
the thing is i thought wow i'm going to
come in here this is a hostile audience
you're not going to want want to hear me
say how scammy this whole thing is and
how whatever but i put it in a positive
light what i said is look instead of
trying to make money from finding the
next person to come along who'll buy
some token for more than you paid for it
why don't we get these things to form
value chains where if you have a token
for some piece of art and some person
uses that art and animation and then
somebody else adds music to the
animation and somebody else adds a story
and somebody else does this and that and
then it eventually makes money because
people want to pay for it then if
royalties go back to everybody
then instead of selling the token you
could earn royalties and dividends on it
and fund a society because
one of the fundamental problems with
tech culture and money in general is
that it has forgotten what money is for
if you go back to adam smith or anybody
who's been concerned with how money
works
the idea is that when you have money
that money goes to work for society
that's how you earn interest on it and
the money goes up in value
the worst thing is to stuff your money
in a mattress and pull it out of
circulation right
and yet
the tech industry has sort of been like
putting money in a mattress and that's
even more so with the web 3 and crypto
stuff
and so what's funny is when i said this
i thought they were going to be angry
but i have this whole hall of people who
started applauding and then they stood
up and it's like i think everybody knows
in their gut that the way we've been
doing things is silly and we need to be
more focused on real productivity real
investment real accomplishment real
achievement real building real
innovation
and just moving bits around and screwing
around with other people's behaviors
doesn't actually do anything for the
future
and everybody really is in it for the
future at the end of the day that's why
people get into tech
so i
it might just evaporate maybe i'm
kidding myself but i have this feeling
like
there's this and this this is a very
young audience so these are new people
and not not the same old people i've
been talking to for decades and
i just have this kind of optimistic
feeling that they're open to it and that
there's room for tech culture to improve
i really believe that
yeah well i know what you mean jared
because i think as we i said to you
right at the beginning when we started i
think
while many of us are grateful for the
tremendous opportunities that being
connected with 8 billion other people
have given us at the same time we cannot
ignore some of the terrible downsides
whether they are for society or for our
children or for our own well-being or
any of those things so and i think a lot
of people are starting to to wake up to
that and the other thing that i
resonated with me so strongly is when
you were talking about you know these
are nerds who who've got their own
sort of not quite as evil agenda as it
might be but i was thinking the whole
time you were talking yeah but that's
because they owned the thing that they
created what happens when they all get
forced out or they die or whatever who's
gonna come in and replace them yeah yeah
i i think about that all the time like
who's gonna who exactly is gonna inherit
facebook or meta right now
it's not set up to allow anything i mean
now cheryl just left and instead of a
new cheryl it's just even more
concentrated and that is not the way to
create an institution for the benefit of
humankind you have to see beyond
yourself and it's it just hasn't
happened yet
so let me ask you about that john
because you talked about how this could
all have been done differently and you
spoke about it at the time and the
biddle's business model is wrong
how do we fix social media or how do we
make it better how do we make it
slightly less worse at least
yeah slightly what's worse that i'll
live with that um i think it's a really
huge
problem to say oh i'm gonna fix it i'm
gonna make everything better and
everything's gonna be perfect because
that you whenever somebody says that you
know
this is gonna be really crappy if it's
like i can make this slightly less
horrible you know that's the person you
want to listen to right so
um i think there's a few things that can
be done differently um one of them if
anybody wants to the current uh issue of
the atlantic magazine in the u.s has a
peace of mind on how to fix twitter
that i wrote for mr elon and uh
perhaps to no effect whatsoever we shall
see but what it proposes is um
is an idea that
i think is the least invasive and
least
impinging on free speech way of just
improving the conversation and that is
to demand that people form small
associations like form little zines or
bands or clubs or brands small enough
that they can all know each other and
only publish through those and
rise or fall in terms of reputation and
monetary income together in in that band
like you two are doing with your your uh
production here right
now here's the reason why i'm saying
that um
if you look at all the people who've
studied societies that you'd want to
live in
they've all come to the conclusion that
that mechanism which is often called the
societal institution is at the core
of maintaining quality
all right uh some of the people who
talked about that are de tocqueville uh
hannah arendt but you know the one that
really got me going on it some time ago
was a friend of mine named muhammad
yunus who won a nobel for starting
microlending
and
there's a lot of ways that microlending
has
perhaps not achieved all that some hope
that would achieve but let's leave that
aside there's one part of it that's
worked really well which is
um he had a bank in bangladesh trying to
serve a super poor community where
nobody had a credit rating if they gave
somebody a loan chances are the person
would not pay it back because like why
would they it was just free money they
weren't even used to the whole thing and
they said okay
we're not going to do lunch to
individuals anymore you guys have to
form a group you have to vouch for each
other if one of you doesn't repay you
all are going to pay the price for it
and this is a way that we can distribute
the process of credit
creating credit or if you like creating
quality
and it worked they suddenly got better
repayment rates than traditional banks
are used to
incredible so when people have a bit of
a shared stake they start to watch out
for each other and if somebody runs into
legitimate trouble other people help
them if somebody wants to screw around
they get rejected they get ejected from
the group and suddenly you have quality
going up magic right and so i would like
to see that in social media and it would
be strictly by free association if you
don't like your group you can always
quit you can get into another one
a group can decide who to accept to
reject but the point is that the groups
are small enough that the people really
know each other
and then
what you get out of that is a few things
one
if somebody starts turning into a jerk
and everybody turns into a jerk online
from time to time
because we turn into a jerk from time to
time offline i mean let's you know be
honest about ourselves
the other people say hey you know what
cool it this is like a bit much but
another great thing is
the group can post often enough to keep
the brand going and to keep subscribers
whereas individuals have to post too
often to do so and to stay sane
so that's a good thing
another really good thing is that since
the group is divvying up benefits
and i want them to get subscriptions
donations micropayments i'm really into
money for this i think i think there
should be more money online i really do
because we live in a market world and to
say well the online world won't be a
market world just makes people become
gradually more and more obsolete as
technology gets better it's like too
it's ridiculous like
if we're going to be socialists we have
to do it everywhere we can't just do it
online so i'm like really pro capitalism
online because i think it's the most
viable way to make things workable but
anyway um
if if there's a bot if there's a fake
person in your group and that bot is
getting some of the money you have
suddenly a motivation to get rid of the
bot
right and now you know when elon musk is
saying oh there's too many bots on
twitter he's absolutely right
a friend of mine at facebook tells me
that 99 of the new account applications
are from bots by their estimate
and the reason
is that people who want to mess up a
society put in bots in order to sway
opinion
right so there's every economic
incentive to make bots well now there'll
be an economic incentive to get rid of
bots
the troops and otherwise it's the
platform's job to do it from on top
which is a losing game but if it's
distributed
just like creating credit and
microlending all of a sudden it becomes
doable we can get rid of the bots which
are terrible they're poisonous
there are many other benefits you can
read the piece in the atlantic if you
want um
so another thing i'll point out
is that i've tried to do a ranking of
the relative degree of terribleness in
different online platforms
how often are people jerks and there's
nothing's perfect
but the thing is it's human being so
nothing's ever going to be perfect
right
but there are differences okay so um
some of the places are really a cesspool
pool
facebook is junk
horrible
youtube is really pretty bad you can
manage your experience on it to make it
better but it's
really pretty awful
there's an experiment now some people
challenge me and say no this isn't true
but i've done this many times and in my
experience having done it dozens of
times which is not a huge sample so not
up to scientific standards but
if i get a room full of kids and i say
okay just either start with your account
or start with an um with a fresh
identity where google doesn't know who
you are and just like youtube recommend
follow-up
uh videos how many tops does it take
until you end up in some really weird
creepy paranoid ugly thing
and i usually found it to be in the
teens like in the late teens of times
sometimes sooner sometimes later but
that's horrible that's horrible so
youtube youtube's garbage
youtube successful despite many many
wonderful valuable things on it
um what's something that's better um i
might be biased because i work with
microsoft but github
this uh place for sharing uh projects
is pretty good there's an occasional
jerk on github but mostly people have a
stake and they have a shared stake with
people in their teams so it's a little
bit like the thing i'm talking about for
social media
where you know if you're working with a
bunch of people on a coding project the
last thing you're going to go and do is
mess up the value for everybody by
mouthing off at somebody for no reason
like all of a sudden you feel a bit of a
sense of
of uh responsibility to your mates your
compatriot right
it's a good thing so um
and i believe in monetization because i
believe when people have a stake when
they have something to lose
they'll think through their actions more
if the only thing you the only thing you
have to gain is attention and you have
nothing to lose then you'll be a jerk
because you you get the incentive right
it's really simple
so i want to monetize this stuff and
then people say oh but i don't want to
have to pay but the thing is if you're
earning paying won't feel so bad like if
somebody's gainfully employed it doesn't
bother them to pay for stuff that keeps
other people gainfully employed so they
can afford to buy whatever they do
like if people
are part of the cycle of the economy and
are part of a social contract that makes
sense
they're more ready to pay for stuff
and we already know online that people
pay for stuff sometimes it's possible
it doesn't have to be all the time
doesn't have to be like this religious
thing that you never have an exception
to but
we just need a lot more of it
and jaron you're talking about you know
social media platforms and you mentioned
facebook and i agree with you in youtube
as well to me the worst one is instagram
it's the worst one and there's somebody
who used to i used to teach for many
years go for it go for it tell me it's
the ideal platform for me to do my
bikini modeling so
[Laughter]
i don't know what you're telling me but
yeah no no i hear you i hear you i get
it
but no but just but the effect that it
has particularly on children and young
girls in particular is awful
it's awful
and
you know and then i was reading they
didn't do it thank the lord but then
they were talking about instagram for
kids
i know oh
and and like you can just imagine the
meeting where that came up and somebody
said how can we expand how can we expand
well there's this population of kids you
know
you know it's just like it
it's incredible that that conversation
could even have happened yeah i know
john let me uh were you gonna no no
because no no i was gonna follow up
because to me the the thing that is
awful about instagram it's
the obsession with the physical self
and the the constantly looking at other
people's lives in other people's bodies
and what that breeds in young people
particularly in women and
you know and we're walking around london
now and there's so many people having
plastic surgery and i haven't there's no
studies in this but i go this must be
something to do with what people are
seeing constantly online constantly on
instagram
right well look um a couple things to
say there um
one thing
i've learned through hard experience is
that if a causation connection
seems right it doesn't necessarily mean
it is right so exactly say that the
plastic surgery thing tracks instagram
it sounds right to me but
which i'm trying to keep us to somewhat
high standards of scientific study even
though it's hard with this because it
happens so fast and the only people with
the data are the
creepy people doing it so it's it's
difficult but
i wouldn't i would just put that in the
category of kind of makes sense but not
confirmed
that's my advice to you like like
we should do our best to try to because
we can make all the arguments we need to
and chart a future path without
convicting every little possible wrong
along the way because it won't even
happen nothing will happen anyway so
uh that's one thing i'll say the next
thing i'll say is um
the pumping up vanity has been happening
happening for as long as uh women can
spend money on anything or maybe that
matter just people like
there's a sense in which it's ancient
and and yet there's a sense in which
it's more immediate more programmed and
more
um kind of nasty now than i think it was
before
and
so
it's it's easy and the stuff to get
caught up with this argument well it's
always been that way which is kind of
true to a degree but then
the question of the amount in kind is
also important then there is a
difference down sometimes it can be a
little bit hard to be articulate about
what the difference is but it's
definitely there and i think it has to
do with operant conditioning with this
use of behavior modification as a
technique
well right i was going to say
human beings are the way they've always
been but the tools are much more
powerful and i think that's that's where
we are which is one of the things i
wanted to talk to you about because you
talked somewhat almost romantically and
wistfully about
the early days of of the internet and i
remember that time
uh freedom connection every anything is
possible what are you talking about say
again you weren't born yet what are you
talking about well maybe not in those
days but i certainly remember like first
encountering the mass phase of the
internet right when the ordinary user
was using it right
and i was i used to play a lot of
computer games in the time and i'd have
friends all over the world that i would
speak with we'd build connections we'd
play games together and we'd make the
most outrageous jokes to each other and
it was free and it was kind of edgy and
it was like the wild wild
west
and that was fun and that was cool
and now we are in a very different place
where rather than talking about how much
freedom we all have it's much more about
how do we prevent quote-unquote harm and
and we've talked about some of the harms
that come with social media and the
internet but also there's a lot of this
like you can't say this you can't say
that
amplifying this message causes this and
that do you think the internet will ever
be free again even in the way that it
was
this is why i'm proposing this group
structure i just talked about because
on the one hand if we just say well we
have to lay off because all this all of
this telling people what to say is
leading in no good direction well then
the whole world turns to pot because we
let manipulative creepy people have the
most power and but then on the other
hand if we let things just
if we get control to the point where we
control those people we also control too
much and if you want to see what that
looks like look at china we actually
think that looks like and it's not good
and i think i think china has become a
little crazy for instance in its
management of covid because of the
inability
for people to just communicate in a
straightforward way
i think i think they've really hurt
themselves
uh and so um neither of those paths are
good this group thing i'm talking about
i don't know if it'll work because it
hasn't been tested enough so maybe it
also is hopeless but at least right now
it's it's an idea that's still standing
that gives us an alternative to shutting
people down or just letting society
fall away to the worst people it gives
us a path through that dilemma at least
it appears to you know so far or maybe
some variation of it will but i mean
it's at least a direction because i
really don't like either of the
alternatives right now right now if we
don't go into the direction of the
groups i was talking about we either
have more and more
sensorious behavior online or we have
more and more power for the most creepy
people or we have to just shut down the
net all three of those are horrible so
this is another option it's another
direction maybe maybe
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com forward slash
triggered that's easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter access of easy which
tells you everything you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
it's interesting you mentioned that
jaren because we use a platform called
locals uh which is a bit like patreon
but there's a community community
element to it so it's not just money for
access to extra content it's a community
of people who love our show and you know
there's about 15 000 members in total
there's about a thousand super active
users who contribute or maybe 1200
something like that and we at this level
at least we don't have to do any
moderation
people aren't generally speaking having
[ __ ] fights with each other every three
minutes people are generally respectful
there's a sense of like everybody's
pulling in the same direction and one or
two times when people have got out of
line it's me or francis have gone guys
remember this is like a cool space and
we in which we all hang out and have a
good time and everyone's going oh yeah
that's cool right and people come and go
but i think your idea sort of works but
i suppose
the question for me is
in an internet that connects everyone to
everyone how how how do you do that
right well
all the platforms were cute when they
were small
yeah yeah earliest days of tick-tock
weren't toxic tick-tock is currently
toxic right the very earliest days of
instagram were actually cute as far as
as hard as it is to remember now
so smallness works the question is how
can you make
a network of small things that maintain
the good qualities of smallness while
still scaling to the world so that's
the idea i've presented to you as an
attempt to do
uh
and
uh
it's gonna be a project it's a
civilizational level project i can't
tell you that i know exactly how to do
it i just believe that
through process of elimination it's the
last idea standing i know about and i
don't see anything that kills it offhand
unless you just want to be cynical say
ah it's all going to be [ __ ] which is
you know it might be
it might be but um maybe maybe this is a
path forward um
i think
there has to be a small enough immediate
community
that it's possible for people to really
talk to each other and for not to become
lost in this giant ocean of bots and
unknowability that's absolutely
essential
but um
there has to be
there's another side of it i haven't
talked about
right now
people
the way people perceive the world is
social this is something we often don't
realize about each other
there's an experiment i sometimes do
with my students or if you go out on a
crowded sidewalk and you start pointing
at something everybody will start
looking there even if there's nothing
there and the reason why
is that we evolved to rely on each other
for cues about danger and where to focus
attention this is something that's deep
in us okay so
if you have this giant unknowable crowd
whatever
that thing the giant crowd indicates you
will start to feel so if there's enough
bots in it to try to indicate indicate
that your society is [ __ ] or that the
other society is [ __ ] or whatever it is
you'll start to feel that
um
now if you can turn it into a collection
of groups as i've i've been talking
about maybe you can cut back the total
number of players by
a hundred times or something like that
maybe even a thousand times
now
your interface to that world instead of
looking like this feed from a zillion
people will look like a new stand with
covers that you've started to like and
you can add or remove from your new
stand and start to dive into it each of
which representing a group
and in that circumstance the way you
receive information is given context and
package so
there were horrible nazis and whatever
whatever kind of creepy person jihadists
whatever these people have existed
before but the thing is they always sort
of label themselves like we're in this
magazine or we're in this whatever
when they're just part of the feed it
just makes the whole world feel horrible
it's part of what leads to this rising
paranoia for everyone
if everything is once again
compartmentalized where there's at least
some context context hasn't been
destroyed then if you see
some horrible messages oh yeah those are
the nazis whatever [ __ ] those people so
it gives you that ability to not have it
be part of your social cueing it's an
extremely important issue i haven't
talked about before
so we have to think about realistically
how people work cognitively and how to
just build a technology that works with
us as we are instead of as how we
imagine ourselves
jaren your idea is brilliant the one
area of pushback that i would say is
aren't we therefore just creating more
echo chambers by doing
this um yeah i mean look what'll happen
this is why i wanted to be monetized
if you have a bunch of people just
saying oh yeah you're great and those
other people are [ __ ] then you have a
whole bunch of those how many people are
going to subscribe to that well a
certain amount it might even be a fairly
large amount but it won't be most people
like you know like what'll happen
at a certain point when you get to the
point where you have
bands and brands and stuff
there's a bit of a filter that happens
where if it's just self-indulgent echo
chambery stuff
it'll start to fall
you know this is um there's an amazing
thing that happens like for instance if
you look at the history of music you
might say well the music business is
filled with producers doing calculated
artificial stuff and crappy artists who
got in through nepotism and blah blah
blah blah and all of that is true
and yet if you look at the things that
were hits and the things that persist
and the things that lasted over the
years
at least in my opinion there was kind of
a sieve in which quality stuff rose
you know overall with some exceptions
and we can disagree about individual
cases but
overall it happens and i think it would
start to happen online too
that makes a lot of sense one of the
reasons i think the people that like our
show like our show is they know we're
not right or left we're just trying to
find the answers in a complicated world
and we've got our own biases which we're
upfront about but we're not pushing an
agenda because i do think that gets very
boring and we've seen other people go
through a process where they just end up
in one thing and they're not curious
anymore and i think that's very
off-putting i know what you mean um look
we've done a lot on social media i don't
i i uh we could talk for hours more of
course
talk to us about ai you mentioned you
were extremely skeptical uh and about vr
as well just give us your you know a
cliff notes version of your thoughts on
yeah well look on ai um
just to be clear the actual algorithms
i'm a total enthusiast of and i've
worked on and contributed to
um
to my knowledge
my little group a little startup was the
first to do deep fakes as we know them
and also the first to do snap filter
kinds of things because
i think these types of algorithms have
their uses and can you know and they're
scientifically interesting the thing
that bothers me though and i think that
tends to create a cover for the worst
uses of these things that make them that
can make them feel
anti-human and indeed be anti-human
is this ideology that we're building a
life form in the box now
within and even the term artificial
intelligence suggests an intelligence
you know it suggests that there's some
entity some creature or some you know
something alive in there
and um i really don't like that way of
thinking i want to think of them as
tools not as creatures now as it happens
the single person who did the most to
promote the creature way of thinking
about computers was named marvin minsky
and he was one of probably my most
important mentor when i was young and
then you started
arguing with him about this just going
back to like
late 70s early 80s something like that
and i'd say you know this is [ __ ]
marvin like these things aren't alive
like look at this thing and i know god i
hate to say this marvin wouldn't want me
to say this but he would say look this
lab is funded because the military
believes that if we don't build these
creatures that our enemies will so just
play along and then you get a salary
you know it's like a marketing thing and
i said okay okay you know i did it and
um i think it still is sort of a
marketing thing but it's become sort of
a religious thing it's like we the nerdy
guys get to create life screw those
women like or don't
don't screw them or whatever um like
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna make
these life and um the thing is
everything gets clear totally there's no
absolute truth on this because nobody
can really know what else is conscious
or what else we like we don't really
have
is evolution itself as a process
conscious is it intelligent
you can debate that i think you can see
it either way
the terms have a lot of potential wiggle
room and definition and
whatever i mean it's interesting but you
can't ever come to a conclusion because
there's no way to define your terms and
we don't have
if i if i can get slightly
sophisticated my languages we have no
empirical channel to gather evidence to
help the argument along one way or the
other anyway so
it's not resolvable but we can ask
pragmatically which way of thinking
makes us more competent
i think that's a reasonable question
and thinking of them as tools instead of
creatures makes us more competent
because then we can evaluate them as
tools if we think they're a creature
then we're giving them too much
difference so we never make them better
in the ways we need to so
like if you that's why i really don't
like it when people say oh i'm gonna
have this program that'll make music art
for you and it'll be better than a
person and the reason why is that then
you'll change to make it seem better um
the way is just the ways to put it is
you'll
make your you know what the turing test
is it was this idea from alan turing has
started computer science
and um
it's ironic because if you know anything
about the story he wrote this just
before he committed suicide because
and
it's a it's a long amazing story but at
any rate if you take it at face value
what it says is
if you can't tell whether a program is a
person or not you might as well call it
a person otherwise you're prejudiced now
of course he was he was being
essentially tortured for being gay and
treated as a non-person so there's a
whole level to this thing
that we could talk about but let's leave
that aside for a second
um
the the thing is
if it's if it's true that somebody
cannot tell if the machine is acting
like a person or not maybe they're
behind
you know they're just texting with you
um then it's one possibility is the
machine elevated itself and became a
person the other possibility is that the
human lowered themselves and became an
idiot to believe the machine as a person
the test doesn't allow us to distinguish
between the two
this happened just last week where an
engineer was fired from google certainly
their program had become alive but it's
also possible that that guy became an
idiot
there's no empirical or scientific
distinction between these two things we
can't tell which is which anyway um
people demonstrably are willing to make
themselves idiots to socialize we do it
all the time we all become morons are
gonna try to impress a date we all
become morons to try to impress a
potential employer we all become morons
all the time with each other
in the hopes it'll do some good and
every once in a while maybe it does it
usually doesn't but we do exactly the
same with machines that we think are
people so let's not think they're people
let's call them tools
if whatever it is isn't working let's
say that tool needs to be better
designed
let's not say oh
you know
i guess that's just the way it is it's a
creature no no no no no
and i think this so this issue of
treating them as as tools instead of
people is actually one of the core
problems that got us into the trouble
we're in
because google always conceived of
itself as an ai company and they always
thought well if it's not doing what we
want the thing is it's an emerging ai
and we have to give it the space it's
like a child you let it grow and go
through its tantrums or whatever
and that attitude is absolutely
wrong-headed they're tools if they're
not doing what we want we change them
and john on that speaking of pragmatic
questions to ask in this sort of
conversation
you know these tools from the inside out
we don't
is it not the case that the algorithms
that say determine our ability to search
for things on google they're so complex
now that actually it's not within the
realms of possibility for a single human
being to assess that algorithm in its
entirety
right so this is a uh this is a large
topic to talk about and i am um i'm not
here representing them at all but i'm
i'm uh
the so-called prime scientist at
microsoft and our office is funding and
helping guide the open ai algorithms
like gpt and
dolly and codex that some some of your
uh
viewers might be familiar with and so
this question of can we understand what
these things even do
in my opinion
[Music]
part of the issue is
that the culture tech culture wants them
to be creatures instead of tools and
kind of set them up to be hard to
understand
more than was really needed
now that's going to be a controversial
statement and i'll get a lot of pushback
from people in the field and yet i think
it's true like for instance one of the
problems we have do you know what dolly
is
no
oh you should look it up it's d-a-l-l-e
it's the latest um image generation
stuff so you just give it some text and
you say hey i would like
i would like to have an image of a
robotic pumpkin
uh swimming the english channel in the
style of turner
and you know what it'll synthesize that
it'll come out
and the way it does it is through this
process of sort of randomly starting to
create images and compare
comparing them with images that have
matching keywords nearby and going back
and forth
until it gets something that it reads as
a match and typically what comes out
actually looks like the thing you asked
for it's just astonishing actually now
what's wrong with that well there's a
few interesting things about it um one
thing is if you just give it nothing but
the one word asian nothing will come out
with porn because all it does is it
reflects the primary keywords that were
online and i don't think most the
billions of people from asia really want
that result
i don't think that's great
if you so there's something wrong with
the way we're doing it and so then what
we end up doing is it's a little bit
like the problem of trying to censor
online speech to fix online speech it's
like this
game that you can never win so now what
you do is you create this whole
organization that's trying to go through
the output of these giant models and try
to have them not give terrible results
but you know it's a never-ending it's a
never-ending struggle and it's not clear
that you ever even get to the point
where it's okay you know it's just rough
and
at what point is this kind of safe for
the world you know
um
so it's a that's a tough one
can i tell you what troubles me by your
answer very quickly right
i asked you
whether these algorithms are too
complicated for a single human being to
understand and you're a very smart guy
and you gave me an answer that's too
complicated for me to understand
i'm sorry i don't know but what i'm
saying is what troubles me about that is
if it was the case that a single being
could understand and i imagine you would
have said yes but you didn't
let me give me a chance to finish okay
what i was saying is right now they
can't be understood but i think they
could be we could do things differently
so that they could be understood and
actually better that's that's the big
picture i'm trying to get across okay so
let's suppose instead of saying we'll
just randomly take whatever people
upload into the internet and then use
that as the basis for these types of
algorithms
um what if instead
we said you know what
we're going to put out a bounty we need
better input data that reflects what
asia is and then what some of these
clubs i was talking about we sometimes
call them mids but whatever there's like
these data trusts these clubs of people
like the ones who would publish
um
they would start saying okay we've just
assembled a hundred thousand images of
asia and then
the people running the algorithm would
say wow we just tested that that
improves our performance we're not just
getting porn anymore you know we'll pay
you this much and then they say well you
know we're going to collectively bargain
with you we think we deserve that much
and then they they go back and forth and
what they get is a fair market price so
what you're doing is you're using the
market to fix it and now people
understand what's going on and the
reason you know they understood it is
they got paid
right if they didn't understand it they
wouldn't get paid and so basically you
you end up in the same situation that
you have in capitalism where
understanding is reflected in payment
because the if you're not you only get
paid if you're generating enough value
for the person to be able to pay it or
being willing to pay it so the
successful negotiation is your
validation of understanding whereas
otherwise what the hell would it be so
what you do is instead of saying oh no
how can we fix this horrible thing we've
made you say um
how do we motivate people to make a
wonderful thing
all right that's the answer to say oh
i'm going to have these eggheads people
like me who are going to understand it
is ridiculous because you shouldn't even
trust us like suppose we could
understand it do you want to trust me
200 no of course not that's not how
civilization should work do i want to
trust a marketplace
made of groups of people who are earning
their way to improving the performance
of these things yes i like that and then
what i like also
is that then every time there's some new
algorithm or some new robot instead of
the people saying oh no this thing's
going to put me out of work i thought i
was going to make a living as an artist
but now this thing's going to make the
art what will i do i'll just be living
in the street
instead they say oh this is a great
opportunity i'm going to join one of
these groups and we're going to improve
that thing because right now it's
garbage and we're going to make it
better we're going to get paid for it so
it takes it inverts the whole thing and
turns what we call ai
into this endless infinite set of new
opportunities instead of this thing that
makes people feel obsolete
and that's what i call understanding
well that is a beautiful message to end
on how realistic that is we are going to
find out jaren lanier it's been an
absolute pleasure we're going to ask you
a couple of questions from our
supporters for our supporters but before
we do in in that local group that i told
you about right the small group people
working together
uh but before we do we've got one final
question for you which is always the
same
what's the one thing what we're not
talking about that we really should be
oh that's interesting
does ai fulfill the same emotional needs
as your ridiculous royal family for
people
you're gonna have to expand on that a
little bit
well as an american i was looking like
what is this royal family why is it
there why is what is all this
fascination it's our class system
darren well no but the thing is it's
this see i think ai sort of is too it's
like it's this it's a set of principles
that come from very powerful people that
are supposed to run society um
you know
i'm starting to feel like this whole
gamut is falling flat never mind my
[Laughter]
if people want to find your work
online uh where's the best place to do
that where is the best place to to
engage in this wonderful moment the last
the last book i wrote was um wait which
one i'm not sure if i remember the order
the last two were called dawn of the new
everything which is a memoir of the
early days of of virtual reality in the
80s
and the social media book i wrote was
called 10 arguments
for deleting your social media accounts
right now in the uk and
uk adjacent countries around the world
it's published by boldly head
which is a fun a fun publisher you have
and uh
um
i think on the the vr memoir the head is
wearing a headset um it's an actual it's
a head anyway um and then there's two
more books coming out but i'll i'll
leave you
all
leave us in suspense about those well
look uh if
if you did give us your time once again
when the books come out to chat about
what you're talking about and then we'd
be very grateful uh don't go anywhere
because we're going to ask you a couple
of questions for our locals but in the
meantime thank you so much for joining
us and thank you for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
oral show all of which go out at 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
do you see a connection between the
emergent use of social media and virtual
reality and on the other hand the growth
of
the feeling that we sort of all get to
choose our own identity
[Music]
you